a former Army mechanic who is
responsible for maintaining and
retrofitting the black tusks combat
infrastructure micro is one of the
reasons we keep having to deal with
those bloody warhounds and drones but
this target actually brings something
else far more interesting back into the
picture someone we haven't seen or heard
from in a while
[Music]
[Music]
on his 18th birthday Sean micro Clark
enlisted in the Army after basic
training he was deployed into
Afghanistan growing up micro was always
very mechanically minded he loved
figuring out how things worked by
pulling them apart and then putting them
back together
in the Army he would rise to the rank of
Sergeant as a mechanic but it wasn't
long before he would have to take a
leave of absence so that he could take
care of his mother who had been
diagnosed with cancer
Michael and his mother were very close
and he would do whatever was needed in
order to help her get better
unfortunately the medical bills were
just becoming too much to manage
he would need to find a new line of work
something that would pay enough to cover
the mounting bills and support his
family
Jack Bonnie would go on to recruit micro
into the Black Tusk
as someone with a strong set of Ethics
this was a challenging decision for
micro but given the position his family
was in he set his morals aside in order
to help his family survive
now for a quick word from this video's
sponsor me you may have heard me mention
once or twice that I recently started
another Channel now I'll be upfront and
honest and say that this is not
specifically a gaming related Channel
over the years I've had a lot of people
ask for help around starting their own
YouTube journey and while social media
influencing certainly isn't something
that interests me creating videos is
so I've created the space as a place to
point people towards when they approach
me it's somewhere to help them get
started
as you can see there isn't a huge amount
of content up yet as I'm just uploading
when I have the time between my other
two channels but check it out if this
interests you or if you'd like to show
some support I'd very much appreciate
any subs and likes on the videos to help
get the channel off the ground there
should be a link up in the top right
corner now but otherwise let's get back
to the video
I need more batteries Vic I gave you
enough for six months you don't need
more batteries you just need to charge
them and how do you suppose I do that
Vic use one of the solar relays plug
into the local grids put up a wind
turbine pick your poison that takes time
Vic we don't have time
tell you what I'll give you all your
dead batteries and you can charge them
while I blow up that hostile encampment
to make sure you're safe by hostile
encampment you mean that Village By The
River a village armed with assault
rifles Vic they're not a threat I still
got a job to do and all I see is on
threat make yourself useful and fix my
batteries
you may remember this name from very
early on when we were helping the
theater settlement get up and running
the batteries powering their
Communication System were beginning to
fail agents were sent to odia tech
office declare out the hyenas holding
the complex to see what they could find
they may be able to help them
out there I've told you before
[Music]
now keep your head down on your shorts
untwisted Malik we'll take care of this
[Music]
hey whoever you are let me out of here
[Music]
that was an impressive performance
afraid I can't say the same for my own
efforts
thank you
the hyenas have been keeping me here to
repair their gear
if you were hoping to find anything
useful here you're out of luck
well the battery packs we came looking
for already here but hey you rescued a
civilian and that's a victory and who
knows maybe Mal could be able to help us
out somewhere down the line let's call
this one agent move out
after rescuing Vikram he offers to
assist the agents with locating some new
battery packs they agreed to meet up
with them at the odia retail store
the basement beneath this store contains
the battery packs you need as well as
the only computer in DC that can still
connect to the odia network I need to
access data on that computer
get me there and the batteries are yours
my key card no longer works
but I'm guessing you can bypass this law
[Music]
the battery packs are in the basement
below us
head down there now and we can both get
what we came for
files deleted
the doors are coming
the doors are okay
he said that
oops I seem to have tripped him on every
hyena inside two blocks is probably on
their way here to investigate
sorry to leave you like this but I can't
take the chance of those [ __ ]
catching me again
best of luck agent
I think you're gonna need it
I see a group of hyenas heading into the
odea store
the bastard milk screwed us
at least you got one of those battery
packs but getting it out of there isn't
gonna be easy
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[ __ ]
whenever he was trying to hide he was
willing to kill you to keep it a secret
but you survived you got one of those
battery packs
we'll send a team to pick up the
remaining stock with any luck the
theater's communication problems will be
a thing of the past as for Malik
I'm guessing he'll keep his head down
for a while
so basically the agents rescued the
crown he offered in a way to thank them
by helping them find the batteries they
were looking for
but instead it's a setup the agents are
ambushed by hyenas after he sets off an
alarm while he escapes leaving them
there to die and up until now we've
heard nothing about him since however it
doesn't sound like he's been having a
particularly good time he appears to
have been picked up by the Black Tusk at
some point and they're using him to keep
their equipment powered
unfortunately for Vikram the black tasks
have now realized how much of a pain he
is and have reevaluated his importance
to them based on how useful he really is
to their cause
Vikram Malik is a problem is Vic a
problem or are you concerned that he
might be a problem concern what did he
do now I think he's holding out on us
there's nothing left to hold out
Vic has served his purpose maybe it's
time to let him go don't we need him to
charge the warhounds Vic was always a
temporary solution to an immediate
problem
I'm working on something more
permanent what do you want me to do with
him whatever you think is right
I thought you said you were out of
batteries no I said I gave you enough
for six months
I never said I was out of anything
you're an [ __ ] I know well
now I really don't know what to do with
you what is that supposed to mean I mean
the boss lady told me I could do
whatever I wanted with you
cut you loose
kill you
put you back to work
I was gonna kill you but now I'm not so
sure that's great hey you've done a lot
for this organization
and I know we wouldn't have been able to
get this far without you so part of me
feels like you've done your service and
should be rewarded for that and the
other part thinks you just like [ __ ]
with me and making my day harder
that makes me want to kill you
you're not alone
plenty of people want to kill me
I'm still here yeah
I don't think that means what you think
it does Vic
having a lot of people wanting you dead
ain't some kind of badge of honor
it means you're an [ __ ] oh I'm aware
micro see now the way you just said my
name like that
makes me want to kill you again
it's your defenseless unarmed nerd who
sells batteries
man it wouldn't be a fair fight
doesn't even seem right well since I'm
so defenseless and the world is so
brutal now
why don't you just leave me at the next
port and we'll see what kills me first
starvation
wild animals or one of my many enemies
it's not a bad plan
sounds fair
sounds right
yeah
I think she'll like that outcome
division agents receive until that micro
is located somewhere in federal triangle
Washington DC micros forces could be
found causing chaos all over the
district public executions controlling
territories the kidnapping of civilians
and setting up outposts and strategic
areas
while sweeping through and clearing out
all the Black Tusk soldiers they come
across the division agents would
eventually discover micro's location the
Viewpoint Museum
the compound was filled to the brim with
countless numbers of drones warhounds
and mini tanks in hindsight the agents
could have made things much easier for
themselves if they'd just use EMP skills
I mean all the hints were there
beforehand but regardless they managed
to fight through
micro had backed himself into a corner
and with their Superior training and
Equipment it wasn't long before the
agents had eliminated him and his
personal guard
this seems to be the season of targets
with Annoying voices so far with trench
and now micro speaking of which I'd love
to know the story behind his nickname
the crane may have been snatched up by
the black task long before the agents
rescued him or maybe in between the two
side missions but I actually don't think
this was the case he doesn't seem to
heavy any allegiance to anyone but
himself
as many told us before we found him in
the retail store he was dismissed from
his role at odia a few days before the
outbreak first hit he seems to have some
other agenda and not just the deleting
of all odier files that he blatantly did
in front of us something else something
worth trying to kill the agents over
I'm not sure what it is but I get the
feeling we'll be finding out soon it
would appear that micro released him
into the wild if I was a betting man I
would say that the division will be
picking him up very soon and if that's
the case I hope we're given the
opportunity to you know slap him around
a bit because God he's a dick
I realized I haven't covered any of the
many in lewiscom's yet but I'm just
feeling them out for now it all seems a
little bit too obvious where these are
going so far so I'm looking out and
reading into them further to see if
there's anything I've missed otherwise
thank you very much for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one cheers
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]